you remember when president trump during
the campaign posted that
meme to twitter and it was a picture of
him
and it said they're not coming after me
they're coming after you and i just
happen to be
in the way i thought it was one of the
high points
of the 2020 campaign and jack dorsey
twitter ceo just proved it true
jack dorsey obviously just de-platformed
president trump
the other day he was just caught on a
hidden camera i believe from project
veritas
pointing out on a phone call this is not
about trump
the censorship is going to be much much
broader
we do intend to do a full retro as i
said in my
it is going to take some time um and
then
the other thing just to just to close
out
a little bit we you know we we are
focused on one account right now
but this is going to be much bigger than
just one account
and it's going to go on for much longer
than just this day this week
in the next few weeks it's going to go
on beyond the inauguration
we have to expect that we have to be
ready for that so
the focus is certainly on this account
and how it ties to real world violence
but also we need to think much longer
term
around how these dynamics play out over
time
i don't believe this is going away
anytime soon
and the moves that we're making today
around
uh for instance is one such example of a
much broader
approach that we should be looking at
and in going deeper on so the team has
a lot of work and a lot of focus on this
particular issue
we also need to give them the space and
the support to focus on
the much bigger picture much bigger much
broader you see he's using the excuse of
real real-world violence
to take trump off of twitter it doesn't
really justify it at all doesn't it
doesn't explain the real-world violence
that trump is inciting
right trump is tweeting out saying be
peaceful be peaceful be peaceful
but he's basically admitting that's just
an excuse because this is going to be
much broader
then he says okay and then we're going
to broaden out and talk about q
anon but even that that's not the extent
of it this is going to be
much much broader it's going to go on
for weeks and months
it's going to go on past the
inauguration
big tech the ruling liberal regime of
which big tech plays a
plays a role has had it with
conservatives and they want to
ostracize us from society they say
make your own twitter if you're a
conservative and then you make your own
twitter
and they kick you off of the internet
parlor tried this
parlor was dan bongino's platform you
know there was the twitter alternative
then they they go and you know they're
getting a lot of new members when
twitter starts purging right wingers
and then amazon web services kicks
parlor off we were told that parlor was
supposed to be back
today parlor is not back today
parlor according to its ceo may never
return
why is it is it because parlor
just doesn't have a good business model
i don't think so i think parlor can
attract a lot of money i mean you've
heard
people financial analysts talking about
how well parlor is doing
is it because parlor doesn't have a good
user base
no parlor last i checked had 2.3 million
active users
and 15 million total users and that by
the way was before this crazy
week of kicking trump off of twitter and
everybody going over to parlor so i'm
sure that number went up
considerably many multiples perhaps well
it's not because of that
it's because the left does not want the
right to have
any say they want the right to be
totally
ostracized it's not about trump that is
a distraction
it's not about cue anon that is a
distraction
it's about you it's about the 75 million
trump voters people who mainstream
leftists have said
are nazis neo-nazi white supremacists
and therefore totally
should not be permitted in society it's
it's interesting on a few levels how
this works because what they do
they've been doing this for a long time
they call you deplorable irredeemable
bitter clingers right all these sort of
ways to dismiss you and
and justify taking you out of society
but the
the top charge probably is that you're a
nazi
right you've been hearing this ever
since gore vidal was debating bill
buckley
many many years ago he said you're a
crypto nazi and bill buckley threatened
to punch him in his face
they call you nazis because that that is
in popular culture considered the
embodiment the incarnation of pure
evil right there can be nothing even
close to that amount of evil
why is communism not considered on that
level
communism a bloodier ideology
right and and certainly i think in the
ballpark of wickedness and
how pernicious these ideologies are
right
why is it perfectly fine to be a
communist why are you permitted to wear
a che guevara t-shirt could you imagine
if you were a nazi t-shirt oh my
goodness gracious
but you can wear che guevara you can
wear chairman mao you could probably
wear a stalin t-shirt on a college
campus
wouldn't get you into any sort of
trouble
it's a strange strange double standard
meanwhile the 75 million americans who
voted for trump
are not nazis but it doesn't matter
because if you if you just say
75 million people disagree with me
they're not liberals they're not very
progressive
then it's hard to justify kicking them
not just off of social media but out of
banks
out of their jobs out of their
livelihoods right but if you say they're
nazis then yeah sure we don't want we
don't want to do business with
hitler do we i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the michael knowles show to
check out the full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you